I want to pull up this tweet that I have
and credit goes to Luke on this one
actually I saw Luke tweet this out so I
actually went and checked and it's true
the world government Summit 2022. that's
what it's called
has a video titled are we ready for a
new world order in it the host Becky
Anderson says are you ready for a new
world order
and this Channel World Government Summit
is verified by YouTube and YouTube added
a context fact check that says the New
World Order is a conspiracy theory which
hypothesizes a secretly emerging
totalitarian World Government they have
that tag on a video that is from the
verified Channel World Government Summit
you can't make this stuff up I'm sorry
many people are saying we're in a
simulation we're in a sitcom
yeah what is that duck called double
speak where it's like you know you're
holding the booger this ain't a book I
mean but it's a book but it's not a book
all right it's the book but it's but
it's not that's so good yeah two plus
two equals five accept your reality as
we tell you it is don't you dare
question it we're building a new world
order but we're not building a new world
order because if you say we're building
a new world order you're going to get
punished and screwed and demonetized and
downranked in the algorithm wait wait
and we're gonna make sure no one sees
your videos fact check fact check I have
to apologize correction everyone I now
recognize why I'm so wrong about this
the context provided says a conspiracy
theory which hypothesizes a secretly
emerging totalitarian World Government
this is overt stated and in your face
not a secret it's a different New World
Order the one public facing one well no
no quite simply put the conspiracy
theories that they're trying to keep it
a secret no they're straight up telling
you they're doing it yeah yeah I think
it's funny I was there I almost tweeted
at you last night I don't normally tweet
right at you guys but like uh that I
think that what's happening is the
global economic system is like in order
to avoid world war three this is like
through City's trap we're gonna just
transition the new world superpower to
become China and then so now they're
moving they're corrupting our economy
they printed us out of a bunch of money
they really I think people really don't
understand or care about the American
Constitution that aren't from here like
free speech is like dude I'm a I'm a
corporate executive I don't you don't
have free speech my Corporation and if
we're going to run the world like a
corporation if we have order you know we
need to stamp down on some of these
people that are thinking too freely
um and then there was more of the Tweet
I'll come up with it later but it's uh
just how do we get to this point you
know for the longest time they said New
World orders a conspiracy theory there
was that Meme uh Sheamus over at Freedom
Tunes he did a meme correction but it's
hilarious where he's talking about the
reverse pyramid of conspiracies and at
the top in like their anti-semitic I
think it's in the anti-semitic point of
no return section this leftist wrote New
World Order is is in this conspiracy
theory bracket and I'm just like yo they
actually have the world government
Summit they're telling you they're doing
it they're not hiding it I think it's
when Rockefeller and his buddies it's
not a theory yeah they started the
Federal Reserve in 1913 on Jekyll Island
they they basically were trying to run
the world they didn't ever want to get
their companies broke up again like
Standard Oil was by the US government
they're like we're done with this
government crap and then we had a chance
to be like federal reserves busted we're
not using it anymore like 2007 Ron Paul
was like hey everyone everyone in the
world focus on this and we kind of did
but then that was our moment to be like
all right we're done with it we don't
need it anymore people might have got
killed but we don't need it anymore and
uh we didn't we didn't do it we just sat
around played video at least I just sat
around played video games I was afraid I
was going to assassinated if I spoke up
silly me so I just keep my mouth shut
and now I'm facing this
so we have to speak up
yeah I think the great reset equals the
apocalypse I think when people think
about the end of the world or when they
think about the apocalypse they think
about this great big explosion then
everybody's gone and certainly perhaps I
mean that that could be an outcome
but I think that the great reset for us
equals the apocalypse it's this ushering
in of what we're seeing as as evil this
is we're not building anything we're
destroying something or they're
destroying something
to rebuild something that we don't
recognize this post-modern this very
pagan
you know this whole world sort of thing
this new system
um and I I I I also you know you think
about again like the Islamic religion
where
where the apocalypse has to come in
order for their savior to come back
I think so it's true for Christianity
too right like there there are cultists
yes absolutely they're trying to invoke
Revelation absolutely sure in in some
corners of Christianity yes you want to
sort of root for the apocalypse for for
this for our savior to come back
um but it just everything Trends towards
destruction we're not building anything
we're not
uh you know we were just talking about
Trudeau and and and what was in the news
today about
um I forget what the acronym for it is
is like government assisted assisted
death or something maybe yeah right what
is that what what is that are you
medically assisted something dying yeah
induced death or something like that
it's and it's it's a it's an awful awful
thing
um medical assistance in dying yeah it
may be like that's that's the that's the
solution there's people who are in there
pain people who are Canada's doing this
I think and there there are people
posting on like Tumblr and forums saying
as soon as I'm 18 I'm getting it right
away yeah yeah the Pod just shows up at
your house I'm a man Bender you walk in
with the coin and yeah suicide Booth the
New World Order it's not a conspiracy
it's something that we're going through
right now it's a buzzword used by many
powerful people as a way to try to
centralize more power money and
Authority for themselves it's been
talked about for a very long time
predominantly from the David
Rockefellers of the world and other very
powerful individuals David Rockefeller
in his own autobiography by the way said
quote this is his own words in his own
book that I actually confronted him with
one-on-one face to face he said quote
some even believe we the Rockefeller
family are a part of a secret cabal
working against the best interest of the
United States characterizing my family
and me as internationalist and
conspiring with others around the world
to build a more integrated Global
political and economic structure one
world if you will if that's the charge I
stand guilty and I am proud of it David
filler his own autobiography I asked him
about it I went I went up face to face
now I was like you still believe in this
let's let's talk about this he of course
you know freaked out and I assume he
said yes but but it was nice comments
there's many of these comments
throughout history but but so let me ask
this why is it that Rockefeller writes
that in his book that George George it
was H.W bush said we could make many
we're beginning to see a new world order
and they're specifically saying a world
order and a new one there's the liberal
economic order and they're talking about
launching a new one this is overt I
think the Council on Foreign Relations
was it uh the website has it discussing
a liberal economic order why then does
the media YouTube Wikipedia I'll come
and say it's a lie and a conspiracy when
they're telling us they're doing it I
think it's because that there that
people are afraid we will establish a
new world order with American
constitutionalism and that could be
upending klaus's dream like we have a
basically the liberal economic order is
is over it's done it's ending we need to
pull a George Washington uh socially
where we say we give the power away we
give it back to the people because we
trust the world and we trust Humanity to
answer your question Tim it's to
demoralize people it's to show them that
we're going to overtly have these plans
we're going to talk about them but you
can't talk about them because we're more
powerful than you are and this is a part
of the larger kind of psyops that's
being played here with this this these
mind games this is essentially in mind
game saying I could do what I want I
could say what I want you can't that
right there is showing the true power of
what the new world order is in its
Essence this kind of larger hypocrisy
and abuse of power as they're using it
to gain more power for themselves I want
to I want to stress this point do not
think of the phrase new world order as a
proper noun as and that's what a lot of
people do they think of new world order
as like a proper noun no no no it is
break each word down to their root
meanings and that's actually what the
phrase is there is the liberal world
order or liberal economic order Ian's
brought it up many many times we've
pulled it up the website from I think I
think it's CFR is that the constant
formulations yeah and there's also the
trilateral commission and the Bilderberg
Group they're all coalescing with each
other and they all talk about the same
right building a new world order and
they have websites published on this
News Guard certified and when they say
New World Order what they're saying is
we're currently in the liberal World
Order now we need a new version of the
liberal world order a world order that
is new the new world order doesn't
specifically refer to anything other
than they want a global system of
control it is not it's not a secret
they've said it over and over and over
again perhaps they're arguing the
conspiracies that people believe weird
things about it I don't know whatever
but they're doing it and they're having
some it's called the world government
Summit it's verified by YouTube
yeah so there you go and it's at the end
of the day what they're calling for is
more centralization more bureaucracy
more power being held in fewer hands
which of course is always ripe for abuse
whenever we have a fewer and fewer
individuals of of more people of more
land uh of more uh things that they
could conquer in subject this is
essentially a form of domination and
that's exactly why there's so much Mind
Games to this where you can't talk about
this but they can you know we need
freedom and I think part of this Mad
Dash towards Global governance is
because Antarctica is about to become
melted and a big giant continent that
people are going to try and colonize and
when they do there will be a global war
that's China and America and Russia all
trying to take it at once it could
destroy the Earth maybe they're trying
to say no only one of you is going to
get it but we think before before uh
Antarctica becomes available for for
player uh use the the last update patch
in the simulation has to occur so that's
the final story which is going to be
probably Trump three three Trump three
the you know A New Hope or whatever you
want to call it and then then we're
gonna get the the expansion pack Earth
simulation to the Antarctic campaign
well you can only rent the expansion
pack you never actually own it yeah
that's what you'll like you'll license
it and then you can create new
characters starting in the and
Antarctica content really excited for
this plus the new skill sets that are
being released I hear that journalists
will get the ability to communicate via
neural Link in the latest expansion I
like Freedom man I don't like the idea
that cops are on the street corners
watching you whenever you walk around I
don't want it if you don't want it then
join me now imagine the crazy crazy
Insanity that you'll have to deal with
when everything's online and they have
control of what you see and what you say
and what they don't say and what they do
to you and what you can you call out and
can't call out but as you said Tim yeah
the CFR website officially says Globe
we're calling for Global governance and
they have an article on their website
what is the liberal World Order and they
go on and explain hey we need everything
in the hands of all these private uh
International corporations and Banks and
we need less representation we need less
people being able to decide their own
lives and we need that decided by
Central controllers I always I always
like pulling up this article from
world101.cfr.org what is the liberal
World Order because it is News Guard
certified 100 out of 100 and it's like
how do you get that rating and
especially like the CFR they're not a
news organization why are they rated 100
out of 100 sure whatever but liberal
world order it's on their website they
say after World War II the delicious
conflicting Ministry countries sought to
ensure the world never again would
devolve into horrific violence blah blah
blah here's why we did it here's what
we're doing so when they say we want a
new world order the saying to advance
beyond their old liberal World Order
where did that article come out because
it sounds like something I wrote
they've been talking about it for a very
long time ever since big Nerf bazinski
and David Rockefeller helped fund and
and start uh the Council on Foreign
Relations and there are quasi-private
not private club they have some public
meetings but but in private they also
have big members of the corporate media
they have a lot of politicians even
weird politicians like Tulsi gabbard and
other of course Mainline big politicians
that are a part of their meetings they
meet in secret and also talk about and
decide policy openly and and and
secretly thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time